On my genetic test you stated to avoid kale. I have the greens that has
fermented kale and combo with other greens. Will this be okay to take it to be
implemented? Yeah well you want to the reason why you want to avoid kale as a
cancer patient and pose back to this idea of one question because kale is
kale is a great product as it stimulates nitric oxide synthase. So
nitric oxide synthase is fantastic or your cardiovascular system helping you grow
new vessels helping for your heart. So you want that you don't have
cancer. So kale is a great thing to eat. It's got more nitric oxide in it than
any other plant product, any other food product. You know it's got three to
four times more nitric oxide than spinach, which is the next virus. But
nitric oxide synthase increases that Jeff, which is vascular in the field of
growth factor, which increases vascularization of tumors. So we don't want to
stimulate that too much. However, you need nitric oxide in your body so it
won't get me wrong. So but you just don't want to be doing kale shakes and stuff.
So if your if your greens has a lot of kale in it, then maybe you want to
switch to something else. Certainly if you had a little kale in your salad or
something because it was in your salad mix, that's just fine. If you you know
if you're making you know your purpose, they buying kale at the grocery store
and juicing it or putting it in your shakes and stuff, that's a long thing to do
if you have cancer in my opinion.